hey everyone dogan here so it's been a
while since i've done a long form q a
video about japan and i got about a
hundred questions on twitter from people
that are asking about living here
studying here teaching english here
raising a family here etc etc so let's
just try and get through some of these
and i'll try and be a little bit quicker
than usual because i tend to drag on a
little bit too long for each question so
first question from my friend ikutri who
is an artist that finally got here on
study abroad so
congrats iku and let's get to your
question oddly enough my current
question is how to create a good
foundation when it comes to
intercultural dating and relationships
finding common ground with serious
communication differences would be
interesting from your standpoint i think
this is a very mature question because
there are a lot of foreigners that want
to have a relationship with the japanese
people and a lot of japanese people that
want to have a relationship with a
foreigner without
thinking about kind of
the nitty gritty and what would you say
well you only think about the ups when
you're thinking about having a
romantic relationship and
when you think about things that
optimistically obviously uh it's that
much rougher when you're actually hit
with conflict down the road so
very mature question again to begin with
but i think in that sense
if if you you got to have some common
ground in a language that each of you
speak
but i also think that more than anything
it's the mindset and i think that if
you're going into a relationship
with this mindset rather than just like
oh i want to date a japanese girl or oh
i want to date a japanese guy
if you're open and mature about things
and you both speak at least
you know one language fluently that you
can you know communicate with if you sit
down with that person at the beginning
of the relationship and be like
hey
we're in an intercultural relationship
and because of that we're going to be
facing a bunch of hardships that
probably wouldn't come up if we
came from the same background
and if you just go in with that
again with that mindset and you're very
open and you communicate a lot i think
that that's probably the best thing that
you can do it's hard to say
you know whether that'll work or not
because there's so many factors when it
comes in
with regards to relationships but i
think communication is key regardless
even if you're coming from the same
culture very mature question and i think
from that mature standpoint you're going
to be off to a good start question from
fruth how are you finding school slash
life etc for your twins in a smaller and
comparatively
less international city like
we just had a kid and tokyo has a lot of
options but i am curious how it is
further away from the bubble so a lot of
people don't know this i've talked about
this a few times in the past but beppu
is actually arguably more international
than tokyo and that's because beppu has
the highest concentration either the
highest or the second highest
concentration of
ratio of foreigners to japanese people
of any city in japan except for i
believe kyoto
and the reason that there are so many
foreigners in beppu is because there's a
university here
that well apu where i used to work and
half of the the students there are from
outside of japan they're international
students many of them graduate and
end up staying in between but then also
half of the
faculty so half of the teachers at apu
are also foreign and then many of the
staff so people doing like
you know working at the career office
doing uh admissions recruitment work
like what i used to do
they're also international again like me
non-japanese so many people that
whether they attend apo as a student or
work at apu end up leaving it eventually
and then
just staying in beppu because beppu is a
very very well it's a very comfortable
town to live as a foreigner because
people are used to interacting with
foreigners so when you go into like the
city office as a foreigner or if you try
and like rent an apartment in beppu as a
foreigner etc
then it's it's very streamlined
relatively speaking
there's still a lot of red tape because
i think that's just kind of what would
you say a characteristic of japanese
culture to begin with
but relatively speaking there's less red
tape because you're a foreigner now the
question um that i believe fruit was
asking was
you know
with regards to raising kids here and
the reason i gave that kind of long
introduction is because
the teachers here are used to dealing
with mixed kids as well and
if you
there are so many instances in between
where i've taken my kids to like a park
or something like that and i'll meet
like another mixed family
um like just it happens all the time
it's actually quite difficult for me to
answer this question because i think
that you were under the impression of i
think that you were trying to ask what's
it like raising kids in a
non-international city but again i can't
really answer that because beppu is in
fact a very international city one other
thing that i'd like to touch on for this
question
is that i've been to every major
international school in japan because
when i was working at apu and i was
doing student recruitment it was my job
to try and go to schools
that japanese students were going to
it was my job to go to international
schools and
recruit to try and encourage the
japanese students that were going there
to come to apu so i've been to all like
the private
um
the private international schools in in
tokyo and in yokohama there's a bunch in
yokohama and
osaka and
fukuoka as well and
it's funny because many of them
are
again they're private and they're like
ten thousand fifteen thousand dollars a
year they're very very expensive and
they do provide a very very good
education but because japan is currently
going through a deep population crisis
you know the population is shrinking
you can actually in a place like beppu
there are and many other kind of just
smaller cities in general
the classroom sizes are so small to
begin with
that
you can get even though the the type of
curriculum is going to be fundamentally
different if you're going to a public
japanese school you can still get a very
personalized experience because you can
get a great education from like a a
private school that's fifteen thousand
dollars a year ten thousand dollars a
year but in that setting you might be
like one of 20 students in a classroom
and even if the teacher is a
fantastic teacher i'd argue that there's
still something to be said about a
public school that has like
10 students to one teacher and there are
many schools like that in kind of the
smaller cities in japan so maybe good
food for thought brandon hey brandon
how's it going as an american how do you
feel about the culture of children
traveling on their own young kids taking
the train alone or grocery shopping
grocery shopping etc just curious what
it's like to adjust to what it's like to
adjust to that when it's less common in
the u.s my kids are still at the age
where i still have to accompany them
basically anywhere because they're in
they're in preschool right now so i
can't just kind of like let them hop on
the bus and do whatever they want but
again that's one of the reasons that i
like living in a smaller city like
because there are less people rushing
less people like running red lights and
that kind of thing less things to worry
about as a as a parent when you're
letting your kids go out to play for the
first time so
again it's hard for me to say because
i'm not quite there yet but i do think
that living in a smaller city like this
will make the transition process for me
as a foreigner easier having twins are
there any differences in how each of
them are currently acquiring languages
not really i will say that we mostly
speak english at home almost entirely
it's it's odd because
because of my work obviously there are
instances in which it's just more
naturally for me to say something in
japanese and because i'm very concerned
about well i want them to be completely
bilingual even in instances sp and this
is very true of recently um
in which i i can feel the japanese start
to come out often like
pump the brakes and like okay what's the
right english for this
and then i'll i'll say that instead
because it is getting to a point with
them going to a public japanese school
where
their japanese is starting to outpace
their english by a considerable amount
and
uh i think that i gotta like help them
play as much ketchup as possible so we
read a lot of like you know dr seuss
books at home and you asked if there
were any differences between the two um
and not really basically they're both at
a point where their english is starting
to out where their japanese are starting
to outpace their english and i'm trying
to combat that by doing my best to teach
them as much english as possible okay
how good is the entrepreneur
startup environment as there exists a
senior junior hierarchy how are young
company owners perceived how supportive
is the government and such matters based
on the people that i know and like i've
got like a private accountant that works
here and stuff like that again he also
says like it's yeah it's not that
difficult it's just that not a lot of
people do it one thing that i would say
is that although it might not be
terribly hard on paper to create like
officially create a business in japan
officially create a company in japan
i would expect a lot of
hesitance or not resistance from the
people around you like when i quit my
job at apu um there was a lot of people
around me that were like you shouldn't
quit apu like apu is part of a larger
big japanese kind of um
whole jean
not company i can't think of the right
english word i apologize for that but
they're like you got it like a decent
job right now it wasn't really a decent
job in my eyes but um they were like at
least it's stable at least it's stable i
i was like nope not happening like i'm
quitting apu and i'm going to pursue
this youtube thing and i'm very glad
that i did because i'm making a lot more
money than i used to make at apu doing
youtube and on top of that i like doing
my my youtube stuff like apu is a great
university and for certain people it
might be really fun to work there but i
personally didn't like working there
because
although the school is very very
interesting and very unique
i'm much more
i do better in like creative
environments and that kind of thing so
long story short expect people to
kind of give you some resistance and be
like you might be safe for doing what
you're currently doing
um but again that's just if you can
put up with that and just kind of
ignore the haters so to speak
you can probably make it happen okay so
elizabeth and also aj in kyoto kyoto
first from elizabeth how strict is the
workplace in japan really like
especially in terms of
karoshi so like uh overworking to death
has it become a less intense work
environment in recent years and then aj
in kyoto is saying gaijin seat gender
discrimination in the workplace and then
bullying in schools i think the best way
to answer these two questions is that
japan is not like a single entity and
what i mean by that is
the work one
place one japanese company might have a
fundamentally different work environment
than a different japanese company apu
where i used to work the working
conditions were actually quite good
again i didn't like working there
because it didn't suit my personality it
wasn't because the work conditions were
like really really rough and i was like
overworked or anything like that i
worked from nine to five each day and
then
very occasionally i would do some paid
overtime
and
that was that was it and i didn't you
know make a lot of money i think i was
making about two thousand dollars a
month apu had a great work environment
but uh i've worked at like head hunting
companies in tokyo as well and i also do
some i've also done some translation
where it's much much more demanding
where it's like you're gonna get
compensated based on your performance
and in that sense and also the
compensation isn't going to be that good
so you're going to you're going to have
to work very very very very hard and if
you screw up
you're going to be reprimanded and i've
been in that situation i don't know too
much about gender discrimination in the
workplace but again bullying in schools
this is again very very situational
because
again going back to that first question
there are foreigners and foreign kids as
well all over
so like
my kids are currently going to this
really great school but i know that even
if they changed schools in between that
um
it wouldn't really be an issue because
there's at least like a couple of
foreign students
in if not every
every grade at each major public school
here then at least at each school i've
read a lot of anecdotes about you know
parents that
they've
you know had to deal with you know maybe
like their their hair their child's hair
color or something like that didn't
match like the school policy and
you know just like nightmare after
nightmare after nightmare and
again i think that
generally speaking things are much more
strict here
across the board but
in a place like bet boot where i am i've
never had to deal with that although
japan has a lot of
has
a lot of room to improve in many
different areas
many of these issues that you know come
up fairly often when people think about
living in japan and working in japan or
raising kids in japan for the long term
it's oftentimes maybe a little bit more
situational than some people realize
that's me speaking from my own personal
experience so take that with a grain of
salt lunatic what is the biggest issue
for foreign students in japan great
question i think that the biggest issue
is getting out of the bubble and what i
mean by that is if you're a foreign
student in japan either going to like a
language school in japan or studying
abroad at a japanese university you're
going to be in a bubble probably in
which you're surrounded by other foreign
students that are studying japanese this
happened to me as well and the only way
that you can kind of get out of that
bubble is if you're really really
if you
kind of own it and you take
responsibility and be like
i love these people they're my friends i
love hanging out with them but
i need to get better at japanese and in
that sense like okay they just invited
me out to lunch i'd love to go these
people are great but i'm going to say no
and i'm going to try and go talk to
those japanese people over there and
see if maybe i can grab lunch with them
you know it's great to have friends from
both groups but i've found that if you
don't really go out of your way to try
and make japanese friends
when you're studying abroad in japan
you're going to get like halfway through
study abroad
and only have like one or two japanese
friends and i'd say that based on what i
saw and based again from my own
experiences most of the time those
japanese students can speak english as
well and that's why that's why
you ended up becoming friends with them
so quickly after coming to japan you
have to make the additional effort and
it's not going to be easy or comfortable
it's so so easy again to just
hang out with those cool cool people
that you meet studying abroad because
everyone's everyone's like you everyone
is finally just got they finally just
got to japan everyone's really happy
they're really excited for it they're
all pumped and you know
you're all in the same boat in that
sense you're all super positive and like
oh yeah we're here okay yeah let's go
out for lunch and every time you hang
out with them it's going to be a lot of
fun
whereas like if you try and talk to a
japanese person they might be like on
their way to like you know their uh like
hip-hop dance circle practice or
whatever and you'd be like hi like i'm
an exchange student here i'm trying to
make japanese friends do you want to
like get lunch with me
you know it might be like eh
you know like what i'm i'm busy sorry
and so
you got to get you got to
do the additional effort it's not
comfortable but um i tried to do that
like i was one of i think two or three
students that
left the dorm that i was living in the
international dorm that i was living in
during my study abroad the single year
and i started a homestay like halfway
because the homestay option became
available
um so i did that
and i tried to use as much japanese as
possible and i think that i think that
it paid off four years at this point huh
okay so that's a good example like my
daughter one of my daughters just came
in and she was like
uh
like you know my my pokemon isn't cold
right now and like i i accidentally said
in japanese sold on it and again this is
an example of like getting
getting out of the bubble kind of like
in order for my daughters to get better
at english i can't be doing that all the
time i can't just be like sold on that
mm-hmm
it's so easy for me to say these things
when my daughters start the conversation
in japanese because it's just it's
natural like if someone's talking talks
to you in japanese and you speak
japanese it's kind of natural to want to
respond in japanese but i gotta i gotta
do the additional effort to make sure
that they get good at english and if
you're an exchange student you gotta do
the additional effort to make sure that
you get good at japanese every single
instance every single interaction where
you could be speaking the other language
and you choose not to because it's that
much more comfortable that comes back to
hurt you that comes back to bite you
later on interested in hearing your
experience on ways to save money on
commuting costs food bills etc what tips
do you have in this regard outside of
the obvious like not eating out at
certain restaurants or going to a bar i
can't get too into this right now but
i highly highly highly recommend shinsei
bank and
that's because
if you get up to one of their higher
tiers this applies more to people that
are already working here and have some
savings then you can
use the atms at any of the local banks
or at any of the local convenience
stores like 711 family mart lawson i
think mini stop and stuff like that as
well you can use them for free
all the time and that's that's huge
because japan is a cash based society so
there are times when you need cash and
if you're using like a local bank
especially like a chihuahua ginkgo which
is like a local bank at one of like a
smaller
like you know oita bank or like nagasaki
bank or like saitama bank etc etc a lot
of these banks
they bank on the fact that people don't
know how much the bank is like
ripping them off every time they
you know use the atm after hours and
stuff like that it's like it's two two
dollars gone right there two dollars
gone here here here here and here and
most people don't take the time to add
it up all after the fact and if you do
i i did this and it was like oh my gosh
like i'm like paying like forty or fifty
dollars to oita bank every month because
i have to pay like these two hurikomi
like um
transfers to
like my my employee jp etc and stuff
like that and it's like man like i need
to stop doing this asap so i would say
look into sheen state bank if you're a
foreigner they have first of all they
have extremely good uh
service when it comes to foreigners
that's one of like their big things it's
like we
work with foreigners a lot and they
actually provided me with my my new
mortgage for my new house and i'll talk
more about this in an upcoming video but
they essentially provide all of their
services also in english and they also
have extremely competitive rates okay
this is a great question that i've
actually been meaning to talk about tiny
ab abz tiny abs how often do earthquakes
happen around japan especially the
incident with sendai that happened two
weeks ago my theory is that
japanese culture to a certain extent is
the way it is because japan is
extremely susceptible to earthquakes
it's i read a statistic the other day
that 20 of all the earthquakes that i
that happen each year happen in japan
and that's because japan i believe is on
three different seismic or um
tectonic plates
the the borders of three different
tectonic plates so
japan is just
constantly constantly constantly riddled
with earthquakes and i think because of
that
the kind of cautiousness that's embedded
in japanese culture the red tape the
like double checking triple checking
things over and over and over again i
think that's the result of just constant
earthquakes and
again another statistic that i read is
that there's at least one mega
earthquake like every 100 years
and there has been traditionally a big
earthquake like that and here's here's
another good thing to be aware of if you
if you want to live in japan
so if you don't know about it there's
this thing called the uh nangkai torah
and
what it is is
well there's going to be a giant
earthquake that's going to happen in the
relatively near future in japan and it's
not like it it might happen it's going
to happen and the reason for that is
because the tectonic plates there's the
sea plate and then the land plate and
the seed plate it goes under the land
plate and as it goes down under the lamp
plate it pulls the land plate down and
as the as the the lamp plate gets pulled
down eventually it gets to a point where
it it buckles back it's kind of like a
rubber band like you can only pull it
too much before it snaps
it's it's the same way with these
tectonic plates there's a giant fault
that longs that runs a claw across the
entire southern border of japan kind of
like from tokyo to
um
just a little bit south of that that
rung that runs along that entire you
know uh coast
and
they're
they're expecting a giant earthquake to
happen there
in i think in the 2030s
and if it doesn't happen in the 2030s
it's almost certainly going to happen in
the 2040s it's not a matter of whether
of whether or not it occurs it's it's a
matter of when it occurs and if you look
at japanese history
you can see that a cataclysmic
earthquake along that fault has occurred
every 300 years and we're just about
reaching that 300 year mark right now
and this one's going to be so
cataclysmic because there's actually
like three three different uh
faults
and
every like a hundred years or 150 years
one of those
results in an earthquake because the
land mass like slips back but then every
300 years
all three of those snap back at once and
so if you look it up i think it's called
like that
there was a giant giant earthquake in
the 1700s in japan that was all across
the southern border of japan and i think
it
it was either
the largest uh earthquake that japan has
ever recorded or just
or either number two right after the um
the 311 earthquake that again happened
like three uh 11 years ago at this point
how common is the incident that happened
in sendai like two weeks ago i would say
that
if you're living in japan
if you intend on living in japan for
at least five years you'll experience
during that time i would say probably
regardless of where you live
at least one earthquake that's so big
that you get scared during it even if
it's not
very dangerous you're going to
experience at least one that's so big
that you get scared and this has
happened to me two times at this point
my wife used to work at this place in a
nearby city and when that earthquake
that i was scared
during happened it was so big that the
place that she worked at got destroyed
during it they had to destroy the
building after the fact because there
was too much to repair and it would have
been better just to start from zero so
they did this is common this is gonna
happen if you live in japan for the long
run probably a lot safer to
move into like a proper apartment than
it is to move into like a traditional
japanese
machia like a traditional japanese kyoto
like townhouse or stuff like that i know
that's very popular and cool and
there's a certain element of like
romanticism but it's probably not very
safe and you don't want to be in a place
that was built like a hundred years ago
with completely different building
regulations when another
9.0 magnitude earthquake happens in the
next 15 years or so do you have any
recommendations for a job to do in japan
just try living there just to try living
there for two to three years i think the
probably best answer is try and become
an english teacher there are many
opportunities if you speak english
especially if you're a native english
speaker where you can live in japan for
like two or three years
and teach english here and
and you don't need to know you don't
have to have an additional skill like
you can do it straight out of college on
the jet program and if you don't get
into the jet program you can try
applying to like interact or kind of one
of the other alternatives to the jet
program or you can
depending on where you're coming from
you can try and do like a work holiday
and go to like a smaller private english
teaching school or something like that
it's not terribly terribly hard to do
that if you if you're a college graduate
but um it can be difficult to find
alternatives to the english teaching if
for just two or three years in japan
any tips on
for non-engineers who just passed into
so how to get a job if you're a
non-engineer and you just passed into
for example do you think attending
setsumeikai is crucial despite the
availability of online platforms like
linkedin do they offer marketing slash
sales positions for gaijin in situ makai
so i think this is probably a good
opportunity to also
talk about one additional thing that
i've been meaning to cover
in one of these kind of videos for a
long time and that's kind of the
japanese economy in general
the sad truth is that the economy
in japan is not doing well and it hasn't
done well for the past like 30 years or
so after the bubble burst
the
average rate of the
uh
post
university or university graduate it's
been like at like 2 000
it's been hovering at about 2 000
for 30 years now and it hasn't changed
currently like i think it was like two
or three years ago the amount of money
that the average university graduate
makes immediately after graduating was
surpassed
japan got surpassed by korea like if you
look at like you know
i would say most western countries
almost certainly all of the southeastern
asian countries that are undergoing
incredible growth right now like
malaysia
indonesia
many of them haven't yet caught up fully
to that two thousand dollars yet but
they're they're growing very very
rapidly and it's just a matter of time
before many of them end up uh overtaking
japan chances are if you go and work at
a japanese company even if the work
conditions are good like what i
described earlier i had a good working
conditions at apu i was getting like two
thousand dollars a year when i or two
thousand dollars a month rather two
thousand dollars a month
married
that's not a lot of money and it's very
very hard to save any money at all when
you're making 2 000 a month
in japan
and it's unfortunate because that's
that's what the overwhelming majority of
people in their 20s and many people in
their thirties as well
make between two thousand and three
thousand dollars a month things aren't
trending in a good direction for the
japanese economy right now and
going back to your original question
which was like uh you know
what are japanese companies looking for
again i said that you're gonna most
people aren't gonna wanna hear this and
this is probably not the advice that you
wanna hear but i think it is the best
advice which is that
i don't think that it's good for the
long run to try and secure a career
in like a traditional japanese company
if it's a japanese company that's a lot
more flexible and is investing a lot in
like the employees like here's a great
example i'm playing eldon ring right now
eldon ring developed by from software
and then published by bandai
namco i believe
after
eldon ring came out i think it sold like
12 million copies or something like that
bandai namco immediately turned around
and said we're going to be raising the
wages of our of our
of our employees across the board maybe
it was like just the engineers i can't
remember but it was like it was this big
number it was like we're going to be
raising wages like 30 percent or
something like that that's the kind of
company that you want to work for you
want to work for a company that rewards
its workers and is a little bit more
flexible and is a little bit more
it's not so so rigid and if you can find
a company like that then even if it's a
japanese company even if it's not a
foreign company in japan that could be
really good i think that the the best
thing is to
zoom out
zoom out i think that's the best thing
for most people across the board
zoom out and think do i really want to
work at a japanese company the japanese
economy hasn't hasn't grown
in 30 years at this point
do i want to go work at a traditional
japanese company maybe i want to work at
a japanese company that's a little bit
more flexible a little bit more dynamic
is paying their employees well
is or maybe i want to work at a foreign
company in japan or maybe i want to do
freelance in japan be flexible and be
willing to take some risks because if
you do i think that
there's a good chance that you'll get
rewarded for that if i had chosen to
stay at apu i'd still be making two
thousand dollars a month with a family
of four me my wife and my two girls and
it would not be easy it'd be very very
very hard but because i decided to take
a risk because i started working
i did two jobs for
like three years i did youtube at night
and i did apu
in the morning it paid off and then i
took the risk and said i'm still not
making as much on youtube right now as i
am at apu but i'm going to quit apu and
i'm going to lean into this and i made
it work and i i was very lucky the stars
aligned very well for me but i i think
that that's that's the right choice for
a lot of people given the economic
trends of the past 30 years in japan i
think that's probably a good place to
end this video i've got some pretty
major updates actually coming in the
relatively near future some are related
to the house that i'm building here that
i mentioned i think earlier in this
video but it's gonna be maybe four or
five comedic videos in the meantime i'm
rambling so i'm just going to end the
video here thank you all very much for
your support and i'll see you guys again
soon
you